c'est un scorpion j'ai pas des scansions
chez un scorpion je m'entends très bien
que un capricorne qui mon fils et je ne
m'entends pas du tout et clipping
pourquoi de la balance du lion sans
parler des lions
[Applaudissements]
des poissons en 3ème décan pourquoi vous
dis profondément
parce que je suis partisan de
l'horoscope qu'est-ce qu'on vous annonce
nous arrive et les trois quarts du temps
oui est-ce qu'on nous annonce et de
merveilleux qui vous est arrivé
un mariage
une réussite financière attention il
faut pas confondre l'horoscope efforts
nous vous le comprenez pas je confonds
pas à la fois c'est une chose et
l'eurostoxx et une haute estime qu'on
est les sur un signe fort il faut pas
chanter quand on vous dit que vous venez
de faire quelque chose dans votre
horoscope vous ne le faites pas ah ouais
enfin de moi je ne fais pas ça j'y crois
personnellement que vous devez partir en
vacances on vous dit pas de voyage vous
ne tentez pas de voyage non en nous
prêtant sur la route y compris dans nos
rues
si on dit vous méfier d'une personne
je me méfie toi quels sont les signes
cuir de veau réussissent pas le lion et
le sagittaire et autres gros contrat à
lyon - sagittaire salle et prolongeront
vous rencontre à lyon et à lyon avec
l'ascendant et elle s'agite en
reconnaissant sa défense des classes en
or voilà ça nan ça dépend dans une
maison ça dépend que si vous êtes mais
ça dépend sur quel point moi je suis à
100 du scorpion poissonsavec ascendant
scorpion oui comment vous savez que vous
êtes là sans la liaison la carte du ciel
qu'est-ce qui vous calculez votre carte
du ciel en bas ça je bandais beaucoup la
jackass yves des cours je suis des cours
celle-ci vidéo wii et vous et vous
pensez que ces journaux s'en fait
sérieusement à sérieusement ces
scientifiques ont certifié chez pas
c'est pourquoi vous dire si c'est ça
je peux pas vous dire si c'est certifié
moi on dit et certivea et avait mais on
peut pas dire si c'est authentique de
quel seuil est de vous guider poisson
3ème décan les poissons analysés passage
suis pas d'accord avec vous à l'aller
qu'elles sont bons à bannans parce que
ça c'est général un horoscope il n'est
pas générale ah bon alors c'est pas dans
le journal qu'on doit bien ça n'aurait
évidemment c'est pas dans le journal
vous avez des bouquins spécialisé en
questions les livres sont faits pour une
personne particulièrement pas pour une
personne pour un ensemble de personnes
et comment vous devez vous savez le
livre qui vous vont être au
top d'après votre maison non je n'y
crois pas et pourtant chaque horoscope
qui paraît dans les journaux je les lis
ou pas voulu délai de roscoff si vous
n'y croyez pas j'espère toujours arriver
un jour à à ce que quelque chose soit
vraiment vrai c'est pour ça je suis je
les lis de temps en temps enfin j'y
crois pas trop
c'est plutôt pauvre m
misez
vous y croyez pas tout ce que vous lisez
un petit peu quand même
il croire ce qui est beaucoup dire mais
je regardais soit net de kenshin il
s'agit terre patinent de poids votre
avis
aucune idée de
vifs hors de l'action
mais moi aussi je crois tout les jeux je
lis les journaux est fini le temps des
livres aussi
alors qu'on croyait aux horoscopes mois
oui en partie ah bon mais de quel signe
sagittaire vous regardez les jours
est-ce qu'on vous prédis vous arrive t
elle de fois je regarde jamais il n'en
reste pas parce que déjà pensé qui
croivent c'est un souci en lisant alors
j'ai mis au pas le lire ben si j'y crois
pas
donc si vous avez peur de lire c'est que
nous y croyons non je n'ai pas peur mais
enfin c'est comme les croyances ça c'est
enfin je pense c'est comme les croyances
qui croient en dieu et en a qui y
croient font beaucoup de personnes y
croient beaucoup de personnes se
rattachent à n'importe quoi d'ailleurs
dans la vie beaucoup de personnes qui se
rattache une religion soit une croyance
est automatiquement il y en a beaucoup
qui se rattachent à l'horoscope qui
courent eux les signes représente
quelque chose je suis non non pas du
tout je n'ai pas de lien et précieux dit
quoi pourtant machinalement je regarde
l'horoscope chaque fois que je prends un
journal enfin un hebdomadaire et je
pense que c'est plutôt une manie
qu'autre chose c'est ce que vous
regardez en premier dans un journal oui
en plein milieu d'année de madère c'est
ce que je regarde en premier et j'ai pas
tellement la juge je n'ai pas
l'impression d'y croire j'ai tendance à
consulter les horoscopes
mais quand même
j'aviserai pas
rien de rafah
veuillez les caractéristiques du vélib
votre avis
fonceur
c'est une curieuse horoscope un petit
peu un petit peu oui dans certains cas a
dit blake a écouté je vais vous dire
j'ai un gros défaut je joue aux tirs
c'est le jour pour ne pas vous dire si
longtemps dépendu quoi je vais avoir les
financements énorme y'a plus rien après
lucy des gens
les fonds nous sommes des numéros
gagnants des choses comme ça alors
pourquoi qui ne votent pas
vous n'y croyez pas légèrement
légèrement des prix vous dis-je tous les
jours je le regarde pas exception c'est
pas sérieux non c'est du fruit sans
répondre alors pourquoi ils font ça pour
gagner de l'argent
nettoyer ça
parce que je crois en moi je trouve que
c'est des bêtises battez vous trouvez un
journal ouvert à la page l'horoscope
vous n'avez pas la curiosité de regarder
ailleurs c'étaient les bastilles bon
signe ouais je suis né au mois d'avril
mais c'est un look chine n'en sais rien
ça m'intéresse pas
oui beaucoup je crois la qualif
jusqu en plomb
bourdin horoscope tous les jours oui
tous les jours dans les journaux
je crois parce que tout ce qu'ils disent
est vrai
par exemple on me dit que je suis très
artistique et
l'âge et je crois que je vais là-bas
parce que tout à fait qu'elle m'était
antiste
m
[Musique]
me dis que j'ai beaucoup de chance et
c'est vrai
je vais vous dire votre horoscope d'hier
vous avez bien si ça si ça a correspondu
à votre aujourd hui eux vous avez été
vous avez dépensé beaucoup d'argent
rière non pas du tout j'étais olivier
rabin
horoscope billard vous allez rencontrer
quelqu'un qui va être important pour
plus haut j'ai pas encore rencontré mais
je pense que je la tuerais rencontre est
organisée vous toutes et l'horoscope 10
heures de jeu par rencontre et nuit je
crois pas
[Musique]